all right before we go here on a
wednesday morning uh it is a sad morning
here on good day las vegas because our
friend your friend and ours hector mejia
it is his last day here at channel 8.
what i know nobody told me
oh give him a microphone
before we get to hector though let's
take a look back at some memorable
moments from your time here on the
program
and i have to say i am not
a fan of roller coasters let me show you
our beautiful
coffee beans live on the air as we were
roasting the coffee beans
now
we can smell it you talking a little bit
more about all of whoa all the food in a
few minutes for now reporting live
hector mikia
i don't know where that went i sure hope
these officers do not feel
waffle i'm going to go ahead and give
this
we're going to cover these we're going
to cover them up
alex and john believe it or not this is
that ugly looking waffle i made in the
last hour and look how delicious it
looks with the powder with the sugar
it's a churro waffle with the drizzled
chocolate
tacos margaritas restaurants are
offering a number of ways
a very tough assignment eating guacamole
uh-oh would you call a sheep that's
covered in
chocolate a sheep
that's covered in chocolate
uh what yep a candy bar
candy bar
more of a calm horse compared to the one
previously but i want to say it's kind
of my fault because i just
jumped right on no heather i've had
flowers and also deodorant still and
right from my doorstep and we've learned
uh packaged thieves and hector we
learned that you had your deodorant
stolen so now you can take these tips
and help yourself
but for the record hector
you uh you smell delicious this morning
i miss you i'm going to miss your snow
angels in the snow yeah
yeah for sure
what about you hector what do you
remember
well i'm going to miss you know working
with everyone and just spending mornings
with
a lot of coffee every single day a lot
of coffee a lot of coffee joining you
guys yeah so you're not going to be
waking up at two o'clock in the morning
anymore hector i think so oh shoot
probably i will
just for fun
just to kind of blend in a little bit we
can always
say
you looked really good in that uh
waiters outfit at the mexican restaurant
oh no yeah going to be a waffle maker no
okay no
polo player apparently but in all
seriousness like in your time on the
program you were always willing to you
know whether it was a serious story or
riding a horse or going to nfr or sema
whatever else was going on you're always
game for whatever we had up our sleeve
so
thank you for your for your work we all
miss you yeah it's been a real privilege
thank you guys yeah
we've seen you grow so much and you've
covered some very serious
lots of great work hector you better
stay in touch too here's even a junior
traffic buddy for a little while
he does it all